foreign
Dr Robert trentzel I'm the president and
CEO and I've been here for seven and a
half years we have a 406 bed hospital
we've had a significant number across
the border
um when it was announced that the
borders were open
um and we've had a multitude of patients
uh come to our doors and in needing
medical care we're the only hospital
here so it's not like we can distribute
to uh to other hospitals in the area
where the closest hospital that does
what we do is 180 miles away
so the hospital has been impacted
greatly because none of the migrants
have a payer source and that's our
biggest issue they've come to our doors
and we give them the same level of care
we'd give anybody else if President
Biden walked through the door or if a
migrant walks through the door they're
getting the same level of care they
don't treat anybody any differently and
we take a lot of pride in that our
concern is that we've had we've
delivered over 20 million dollars in
uncompensated care to these individuals
just over a six-month period you know
that's an unsustainable model to have
that unexpected expense without any
Revenue to offset it
we are running out of resources you know
we've had to hire additional staff
we've had to maintain higher levels of
Staffing which in a normal environment
is okay because you have the revenue to
offset that increased Staffing level
that you have to have because you're
having more patients but in this type of
scenario it's a no-win situation because
you have extra Staffing and you don't
have any again offsetting Revenue
because it's not a unfortunately a
revenue producing patient it's a patient
that you're providing free care for
it's unfair to a residents of our
community too because you know we're
providing free care to these individuals
and the residents of our community don't
get free care
what we experienced uh several times
during the migrant surge was that we had
because we had a lot of pregnant females
crossing the border a significant number
that was probably our largest number of
individuals coming in and any one cohort
was was pregnant females and they would
they would just we would just be full in
our maternity unit and we would have to
delay some of the planned inductions for
our residents because of that our
residents here have had to suffer
through that
we have a great staff they love the work
they do they take a lot of pride in the
work that they do and this has been an
additional burden on them for sure there
are language issues there's cultural
issues and we work through those happily
but you know when you think of the case
management piece too these individuals
take at least three times the number of
Human Resources to resolve their cases
and get them a safe discharge as a I
would say a regular patient that's in
our Hospital contacting families making
sure they have a safe place to go when
they're discharged making sure they have
durable medical equipment if they if
they need that we've had to actually
purchase that for them so they could
have a safe discharge from the hospital
because we can't discharge them unless
we're assured that they have those
resources where they're going to be
and you look at that additional burden
in the wake of covid in the wake of a
hard flu season some come in with bumps
and bruises or you know uh fractures
um exposure uh coughs colds but a lot of
them come in with significant disease
we've had to have patients on dialysis
migrant patients on dialysis cardiac
catheterizations heart surgery I mean
you know they're not coming in with with
little things uh the majority of them
many are very sick they have long term
they have the uh you know long-term
complications of chronic disease that
has really not been cared for staff are
they're just tired and but they continue
to to Shepherd through and they continue
to do the work that they need to do to
make sure they take care of patients in
a high quality manner
I wouldn't say it's a public health
emergency but I would say it's an urgent
situation that we have here with the
migrants and if title 42 does go away
and you know we do have another surge it
could be a public health emergency for
sure because when you think about it
human's got a hundred thousand people
we've had over 300 000 people across the
border here that's three times the
population of Yuma coming across the
border and the only Hospital those
people will use is ours that's it we're
just looking for a payer source for
these individuals that we we can't bill
for we just cannot bill for any of these
individuals we contacted our state uh
through our our state representatives
and and U.S senators we've contacted a
mayorcus's office
um but you know people lend an ear and
they're willing to listen but nobody has
any solutions and we've been at this for
well over a year now now we're not
making a political statement about it
we're just saying we need a payer Source
I find it funny that you know the mayor
in New York it's two or three bus loads
of migrants and so all of a sudden an
emergency and we're dealing with you
know 20 million dollars in uncompensated
care here if we continue to have these
extraordinary expenses that are not
reimbursed it could have a significant
impact on the hospital we need a payer
source to have this Hospital remain
sustainable and viable for the future